Vsauce! Kevin here, with a serial killer who
may very well have murdered hundreds. Her
systematic killing spree went undetected for
years because suspicion just wasn’t enough.
What finally brought her to justice was…
math.
In the United States, the most dangerous place
you can go is… the hospital. Yes, doctors
and nurses save lives literally every single
day, but medical error is a significant cause
of death. No matter how hard we try, tragedies
happen -- and by definition, everyone in a
hospital is already sick with something. But
murder isn’t an accident, and a nurse in
Massachusetts was straight-up killing patients…
to impress a guy.
Kristen Gilbert was a nurse at the Veterans
Administration Medical Center in Northampton,
Massachusetts. She was popular with co-workers.
She’d go out clubbing with them in Boston
to blow off steam, and even threw baby showers.
She also seemed to be really good at her job
-- it felt like she was always around to save
the day in an emergency. She appeared to be
the perfect nurse.
But Gilbert was around so often when patients
died that other nurses jokingly referred to
her as the “Angel of Death.”
It seemed like the Northampton hospital had
a lot of unexpected deaths… but a VA investigation
found that the hospital’s rate of deaths
was in line with similar VA hospitals.
So. Case closed, right? WRONG.
Doctors and nurses weren’t convinced, but
there were no witnesses who saw Gilbert actually
do anything suspicious to patients. There
wasn’t any evidence. But there was data.
Here’s a question: how often did patients
die when Gilbert was on the floor, compared
to when she wasn’t? Was there a correlation
between her presence and patient deaths? And
if so… was it just an unlucky coincidence?
Or was she killing people?
The first analysis can be expressed visually
-- this graph shows patient deaths in the
hospital ward between 1988 and 1997 broken
down into 3 shifts: day, evening, and overnight.
The 4pm - midnight evening shift stands out
as having the most deaths, and Kristen Gilbert
worked the evening shift.
But that doesn’t hold for every year. 1988
and 1989 don’t match up with the 6 years
that follow it. There weren’t that many
deaths, and they were pretty evenly distributed
throughout the day.
Kristen Gilbert didn’t start working on
the ward until 1990.
Okay. Okay. What about the really high number
of deaths during overnight shifts in 1990?
That’s an outlier in this whole data set
-- Gilbert worked evenings, but when she started
in 1990, she worked the overnight shift.
HUH. HUH. HUH.
But this graph is still not proof. Variation
in human outcomes is tremendous, whether it’s
education or physical fitness or death. It’s
totally possible that Kristen Gilbert was
present during a statistical blip. It’s
possible there’s some nurse out there working
on a floor where patients never seem to die,
like some kind of Angel of Life! Just ask
Brandon Mayfield whether coincidences happen.
Or the FBI.
Dr. Stephen Gehlbach, who is now Dean Emeritus
of UMass-Amherst’s School of Public Health,
ran the numbers. He looked at 1,641 nursing
shifts over the period of 18 months leading
up to staff taking their concerns to hospital
management. There were 74 deaths during those
shifts -- which is a death on 4.51% of all
shifts, or .045 deaths per shift.
Kristen Gilbert worked 257 shifts during that
18 month period. With .045 deaths per shift,
we’d expect her to be present for about
11 or 12 deaths -- about 1 every 6 weeks on
average.
15 or 16 deaths when you expect 11 or 12 could
be an unlucky statistical anomaly. She was
there for 40. FORTY! A patient died on over
15% of Gilbert’s shifts. What are the chances
of THAT? We’ll find out in a second.
This video is sponsored by Babbel. The number
one language learning app in the world with
over 10 million subscriptions. Choose from
over a dozen different languages and Babbel
teaches you real world, practical conversations
whether you’re learning for travel, business
or relationships. In quick, 10-minute interactive
lessons, it teaches more than vocab words.
You’ll learn about that language’s culture
like slang, holidays, food and drink and more.
Here, check this out. A. O. K. M. T. So whether
you want to connect with someone, advance
your career or just expand your language horizons,
Babbel is the award-winning technology that
has you covered. They even have a 20-day money
back guarantee. So click the link below to
get 65% off your subscription. And thanks
to Babbel for supporting Vsauce2.
Okay. So, what are the chances? Literally
1 in 100 million -- and maybe even LESS.
In the handwriting analysis I did of Sylvia
Howland’s will, Hetty Green’s forgery
matched on way too many points to chalk it
up to a crazy coincidence, 1 in sextillions.
Gehlbach calculated p-values to estimate the
chance of Gilbert’s nursing death-rate at
less than 1 in 100 million… but we know
from the Sally Clark trial that a probability
like 1 in 73 million isn’t necessarily what
it feels like it is. Correlation isn’t causation.
Maybe her patients were just sicker than normal.
This time, that uncertainty was okay -- it
was enough for the grand jury to proceed.
A grand jury doesn’t have to determine guilt
or innocence the way a trial does. They just
decide whether the evidence is compelling
enough to proceed with criminal charges. They
did.
Again. There wasn’t proof. But the math
gave enough context to the suspicions of the
Veterans Administration, hospital management,
and Gilbert’s co-workers to proceed with
charges -- but how was she killing these people?
And WHY?!?
Prosecutors alleged that Gilbert had injected
patients with epinephrine – which you probably
know as adrenaline, which sped up their hearts
and caused cardiac failure. Adrenaline is
untraceable, but the hospital found that it
had a lot of epinephrine go missing during
Gilbert’s employment. And some of the patients
-- like Henry Hudon, who was relatively young
and a paranoid-schizophrenia patient, weren’t
likely to have 3 heart attacks in one night
without something artificially causing it.
But… why would a professional mother of
2 in suburbia become a deranged super-villain?
Well… She seemed to have delusions of grandeur
in which she herself put patients in critical
condition and then heroically tried to resuscitate
them. She had a history of manipulative behavior,
mental illness, and abuse of patients -- as
a home care aide in the 1980s, she scalded
a mentally disabled child with hot bath water
on purpose.
Kristen Gilbert may have been unhinged -- but
she was also in love. Obsessively in love.
Every time a patient coded, hospital policy
mandated that a police officer engage in CPR.
In late 1995 and early 1996, the same police
officer responded to every single cardiac
arrest that Gilbert reported: James Perrault,
Kristen’s boyfriend. The man she left her
husband and two children for. Witnesses noticed
her touching Perrault affectionately during
resuscitation efforts and wiping his sweaty
brow. Court papers show that "One witness
will testify that he observed Gilbert playing
`footsie' with Perrault during the middle
of a code.” Gross.
Perrault ended the relationship, and Gilbert
was angry. On a phone call from a psychiatric
facility, she confessed to him by saying,
"You know I did it. I did it. You wanted to
know. I killed those guys." Perrault immediately
went to the authorities, so… she called
in a bomb threat to the VA hospital where
they worked.
Decades of troubling behavior culminated in
a systematic killing spree that allowed Gilbert
to be the focal point of crisis after crisis.
Staff testified about her access to the adrenaline
that induced cardiac events, and doctors testified
that the unexpected excess deaths were often
relatively healthy, middle-aged men. The same
pattern just kept happening.
Kristen Gilbert was convicted of 4 murders
and 2 attempted murders -- and the bomb threat
to a federal facility. It’s possible -- and
probable -- that she was involved in many,
many more patient deaths that weren’t the
accidents they seemed to be, but prosecutors
couldn’t prove it. She could’ve faced
the death penalty, but a compassionate judge
and jury sentenced her to a life in prison
without the possibility of parole -- plus
20 years.
The mathematical analysis that was so critical
to Gilbert’s downfall wasn’t even used
at the trial. The trial judge ruled that the
statistical evidence was prejudicial, as it
likely wouldn’t be understood by the jury
as NOT being iron-clad numerical proof of
her guilt.
I’ve shown that math can be an incredible
asset in court… or that it can turn innocent
people into criminals. We’re getting used
to scientific and mathematical evidence, like
DNA and forensics, determining guilt or innocence
-- but the reality is math and science don’t
have to do all the work.
Dozens, and maybe hundreds, of veterans are
alive in Massachusetts because of a bar graph.
Math and science don’t always have to put
out the fire. Sometimes all they should do
— and all they need to do — is sound the
alarm.
And as always, thanks for watching.